[Music]
you've now experienced theater and
you've experienced film what's the big
difference there is a difference there's
a very good question by the way thank
you and we could be as some help here
because there may be young actors out
there if not in the crowd watching yeah
I get this question a lot what's the
difference but yeah film and television
and theatre and there is a difference we
can help people come over here we can
explain you need me for this ok here yes
all right I'm gonna lay here yeah so
let's say we're doing a scene okay I
feel like I need an Apple box no no
we're good that's better
I'm not gonna play this short guy like a
Mark Wahlberg movie all right okay so so
this is guys we're gonna come in kind of
tight we needed to be kind of tight okay
we're gonna tie here and then when I
give you that that's good sorry that's
good this we're starting with film and
television and then when I give you the
go-ahead
you just go out wide okay I'll show you
so now we're doing a scene right now if
this were film and television see it's
all right here right right and stay with
me anything I anything that's not on
camera it doesn't matter right this
scenes intense right we're having an
intense stage stay with me and we're
talking about something and it's
important it's really important it's
important and you feel the intensity in
the eyes
okay now that's film and television okay
now Pat now pan out yeah and now we're
gonna see theater different scene
because if they see all of it they see
all of it it's a totally different I
like I think so you know hiding
I think theaters you don't mean it's
it's all a part of it I love that play I
don't know about you guys but that play
do you guys have by the way what is it
these are great by the way did you guys
could you not get into this
[Applause]
you guys how many of these over here
yeah I can get you a pair Oh dare you
she's if you wise if anybody wants a
pair just come to me because I know her
and she can she gives them to me
directly they're great what do you give
them what we give her like popcorn and
stuff we we give them a real good time
yeah if I saw that written on a bathroom
wall somewhere under one of your seats
there's some glide dental floss grab
maybe possibly she gives up underwear I
didn't know Ellen gave it away it's
right it's on a lot you guys could look
into it you guys know I have a pair of
Ellen Honor yes because she gives out
free underwear when you go on her show
it's all about the free [ __ ] I'm in show
business man so you go on underwear it
just seems weird yeah this is the first
you've heard of this I've never heard of
this did you guys know that Ellen gives
out underwear yeah what the hell
verified an Ellen just found out we
don't watch I know
Big Finish no I see big fans of the show
everybody low and wet one
and that's not that's not the brand
that's our nickname yeah I'm looking
back here and I got nothing this is this
is lame I got some gum I could give out
I mean why don't have nothing just like
plague are your are your genes from the
chew or so yeah like is the rest of your
wardrobe all talk show G wardrobe I'm
telling you I I don't think anything
I've got on I didn't I didn't swipe from
someone said or not that's the way it
goes you are an incredible cheapskate
we're finding out we have everything
from different is this like from
justified sure it is from justif you
might actually stay railing on the back
[Laughter]
for kids
[Applause]
you